Hey Joe Joe have you seen my bag where I
keep all my underpants
if you to know what's in it it's my
briefcase did you get it
the briefcase this keys on the facets
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
my name is Adam please call me Jeff if
you've been watching last time we have
started a journey with Jeff Hardy to try
and get all the way to the top of the
WWE but there's a monster in our way
we in it 200
Sammy's in has that title around his
waist and we need it so we've started a
rivalry next month sorry this moment is
NXT takeover and we are lined up for a
title shot as long as this goes well for
us today so Jeff are you ready damn
right Sami Zayn are you ready to go down
let's start this off with a good old
high-flying movie Wow someone more
impressive than I expected
came in say let's keep this going one of
the hardest movies to pull off in
wrestling grabbing a man's arm and
throwing it against the canvas yeah some
big leg drops okay okay I'll get serious
now let's do a bit of spice lying you
really want the crowd on our side we are
at face may be a big elbows Oh Chelsea
went wrong where I will try and get a
reversal and get some points up get our
star rating up here we go
nice work Jeff and as you said
high-flying wieszczyk challenges to the
max we jump from everything we can find
is a sweet leg drop yes mom all the
crowd wants mom Jeffrey I don't like the
here I'm gonna finish it off with a bit
of a splash he's gonna move now he's
gonna get splashed he's starting to
stumble here but he's the number one
contender and he's not going to let his
opportunity slip away that's right
Michael Cole I am the number one
contender and I am NOT going to let this
slip away this title is mine that's
watching about seven hours to get me
it's not going to go anywhere sit around
my waist this works
can I sit on his face from this far away
I don't think this is gonna go well the
anus breaker is fine
easy to do it here we go come on turn
bar cheese I cannot get another mood
what's the fantastic moon well done Jeff
this should set up a title shot with
ease now he's putting out always memory
can every misery we got a couple who
knows does I can't go to three in
Spanish is cooler there we go so at the
end of the month we should have a match
with some is in for that title to get
around our waist and hopefully we won't
be fighting on main event for much
longer
yes yeah in fact let's rub it in yeah
let's do someone I fly in moves from the
top rope can we hit him from this side
this is going to be painful come on Jack
no you can't go from that far away but
Jeff's fine he can take a kick in but
can you son is in can you take a kick in
my god his body's been through come on
just want to think about your hat JBL
doctor if you'll be able to come back as
win this twister food fantastic we must
have a title shot after this all the
hard work seven hours of hard work to
try and get that title around our waist
we are number one contender three and a
half down that's not fantastic but we
should be okay for the next take over
take over there is an issue the NXT
title is up for grabs like we knew but
look in the ring I am not in the ring
it's some random creator wrestler dude
with really bad albums that rings a bell
it doesn't even have a name doesn't even
have a name making his way to the ring
well done so it should be me against
Sami Zayn Sami what you look worse Tommy
you've lost your credibility there Sammy
or begins it from dislocating your arm
as my title I'm so annoyed that I am not
part of this match in fact let's get
involved you see
let's get involved that should be my
title
Sammis I am so upset that I am not
having this fight so I will heckle from
the sidelines I've never seen him do
that before
Sami Zayn your beards rubbish some is in
you're going boldly Peters Pro it's not
working this Eklund there must be
something else I could do a try I just
don't want some ease in to win this
match so we need to think of a way to
interfere without getting kicked out so
then foreign Blaine something the
Creator wrestler can win this and we can
take title from him instead are you
doing something Oh Sammy takes the red
belt right took a cherry how do I get in
who's shortening to get in I need to go
fight new crop hills here we go then we
get on on whatever this is going wrong
from just down
I just just hurt one of them oh this has
gone so wrong what we did get to hurt
Sammy's is so we we swung this much
would be rejected that's alright but
that might be injected but taking my
chair with me I'll be back for your
referee soon
last time he executed that he's gonna
win it he's going to win it what the
heck is five-knuckle shuffle from the
top row baron blade is going to win the
NXT title before I do I'm devastated
absolutely devastated from this day
forward we will now attack you baron
blaze enjoy your moment sir
our belt will still be around my waist
Jeff Hardy's waist is at the WWE and
then he will toss it in the garbage
because we're going for the WWE titles
just changed cannot believe this all
this time and if he was right and he got
a title shot Jackie O championship man
disgusting is it disgusting tender so
beat him up every opportunity we get
that title should be ours
this is the kind of danger we've all
been waiting
you see this Bell to Byron this should
be mine out you should be able to pause
with the belt that would be really good
did you hear the I'll pick you in the
milkers with this remember the name
remember the face Byron blade that these
superstars won't go to to achieve
victory here tonight she's going to be
bruised from head to toe
it's down here if you don't have to get
a title shot because I just cannot get a
title shot the best I do I am number one
contender but I just do not ever get a
title shot dude we got pocket let's
finish with this one tom boy I want to
faraway first one time at all so it's
gonna have to be lunch that will do
crowd a happy they want me to be tight
to be titleholder to be I want me to be
tidy holder you want me to be title
holder so let's do it again next month
we will target Baron blade unless he
loses it in the next match of course
Adam Baron blade has lost his title and
now Samoa Joe has it so we are now
attacking Samoa Joe at every opportunity
we get side effect
up we go Swanton bomb you will remember
the name you will remember the face you
remember my butt cheating you in the
face I have no idea why I said that but
we are starting to build momentum again
for the fifth time
hopefully Samoa Joe will keep all of
this title so we can finally get that
title around our waist very stressful
time but we're doing well come on Jack
keep it going on fleek those eyebrows so
Mordor retains his title which means
it's on your apps that we run in and
beat the bejesus out of him
can I say the Jesus sorry if I can't say
but Jesus will beat the heck out of him
with come with come with a sledgehammer
thank you for waiting for me there Samoa
Joe I will make this as quick and
painful as possible right let's just go
up top downtown hmm I love it when they
jump over each other
and eat the finisher Swanton bomb oh
he's happy in the crowd so that wasn't a
two-on-one but he was happening in the
crowd now it's time to push on and get
that title I said this so many times but
this must be the final few this must be
it
whoo let's have an interview I think mr.
yes interview let's do it in the style
of Macho Man Randy Savage you went out
there and ambushed him tonight why did
you do that
and obviously it's because your brother
no less that's not him is it him exam
mr. gong sterilized okay thank you for
interrupting that's avoid your Latin
French it was terrible right let me get
up and we can have a proper fight job
let's run away here Joey you look a bit
unwell have a seat how many puns can we
do in one backstage segment okay Joe
right over here is a chair Joe Joe I
couldn't care less
no all right let's find something else
let's find something else
hey Joe Joe I've got another joke jokowi
Joe have you been you don't look too
good
in fact you look a bit rubbish Joe we've
been together a long time but sadly I've
got to don't be all know you've just
dumped me instead Andrew yo I need you
to block this one come on job lock it
reverse this one Joe come on Joe
yes job refuses to be beaten oh do you
know how some of your guests if it'll be
the way every morning recycles here it's
so good I'm just gonna stay and just
just be happy about that wonder what did
you think Joe Joe it was a good one it
sure go No hey Joe Boop pick a bones dry
this is time to end the match it's not
over it really does refuse to let this
be over
this must be the end Joe I can't do any
more puns I've run out Twitter fate to
finish the job we are still fighting
right many different objects for new
puns every day I put job for this table
you could say it's a periodic table oh
that wasn't supposed to be me going
through it damn it
fight on hey Joe Joe have you seen my
bag where I keep all my underpants
if you to know what's in it it's my
briefcase did you get the briefcase
goodies on the practice Joe in case you
didn't know this is an open-and-shut
case
lawyer jokes I didn't lawyer jokes love
your puns can you believe this don't
think I can do any more
I adore you it's the weirdest episode
ever right it must be time to finish
this
Joe let's finish this with a side effect
turn around Joe time to knock you out
boom yes at last job has gone down right
we're good new quick enough to call it
there because I cannot keep a straight
face doing this anymore so next time we
are together we will continue our
journey of getting the NXT title and if
we don't get it next time
we'll just jump straight up and we'll go
straight up to the what's the next one
off would it be Smackdown or what it'd
be wrong I don't know um but maybe both
together we will see anyway I'll see you
next time it's been an absolute pleasure
please do me a favor and like and
subscribe to our content because we want
to keep making videos but we need your
support
I've been Adam from PlayStation granade
absolute pleasure see you next time